hey everyone this is Steve landrope with
collider and we're here at the collider
Studio at Sundance which is sponsored by
Saratoga Spring Water uh I really
appreciate them because Sundance costs a
lot of money to be here and we
appreciate our sponsors and I want to
say thank you to them uh I am really
happy to be talking to the people behind
cat person
um and I'm just going to say
congratulations and how much I enjoyed
your movie and I really appreciate you
guys coming in I have a million
questions so um but I I really want to
start with probably the most important
question up front and it'll be for you
and I'm sorry I'm individual um so I
really want to know what working on Sky
High how that performance helped you
with uh succession and cat person
okay well obviously it did
um because as a 16 year old I knew I was
going to play Robert at some point
um
no uh
I got nothing for you but I'm glad to
hear a Sky High reference always that's
by the way we filmed on a college campus
and that was what everybody was excited
about like all the kids were sticking
their heads out the window of the dorm
like yelling at him for being on Sky
High yeah I remember that so uh totally
and and that was like 16 years ago and
those kids are 18 I don't know when like
how they found that movie but
but it really does stick in people's
minds it is the thing outside of
succession that I most recognized for
which is just crazy to me but um yeah
it's crazy to me it's not Chalet girl
Chalet girl one in one thousand what ten
thousand people bring it up and you are
that you just happen to be sitting with
two of them
did you see it before the we shot this
movie I did
I don't think I knew that I was so they
worked with Ed who was your
cinematographer yeah yeah yeah and also
because it's Chalet girl and I don't
like any self-respecting woman would do
yeah well amazing it is a good film it
is a good film Amazing obviously we
agree yeah yeah
all right I'm sure you didn't think this
is the way the interview was going to
start I was gonna say what about Chalet
girl
let's get into it what's funny though in
a college campus I don't think a lot of
them are watching succession I think
they grew up watching Sky High you know
honestly but anyway getting into why I
get to talk to you guys
um so I am curious uh this is obviously
a very popular
um story that many many people have read
and what the can you talk about the
challenges of taking something that um
and bringing it to the screen and and
fleshing it out more than what's in the
story because and I'm not spoiling
anything but where the short story ends
you know the film continues yeah um I
mean I'm not the the writer of the
screenplay so I I'll have to give credit
to Michelle in terms of how she imagined
expanding the story to sort of be to be
fit a full movie experience but but one
thing that was challenging just even in
terms of like actualizing it with with
Nick
um was that the story is really From
margot's perspective to the point where
Robert is more or less a projection
um you're not ever hearing from Robert
you're not ever really inside Robert's
internal experience when you're reading
the story it's all from her side but
when you're on the set with an actor you
have to have a 360 view of a person like
Nick would say well why am I saying why
is Robert saying this and we'd have to
figure out the motivations for why
Robert is doing and saying the things
he's doing and saying so I think it's
just um by definition you have to have a
more humanistic approach to all of the
characters because you're dealing with
living breathing actors trying to like
embody them in ways that are you know
even if he's not always
likable we wanted him to always be
relatable enough that men watching the
movie would feel like there's something
in there that they can connect with
learn from cringe at recognize
so yeah I mean I would say just kind of
wanting to be true to what the story did
in terms of
showing what's problematic about dating
culture and men and women and how we
interact functionally or not but then
also having to give it more layers just
human layers because we're real people
and I have to see what's on Robert's
face too you know even if Margo's not
noticing it the camera is going to
notice it so totally I I hate asking the
generic question but almost everyone
watching this interview will not have
seen the movie yet so can you both sort
of talk about who you play and I guess
what the film is about yeah you want to
go
okay
um I play Robert who is
um
pursuing Margot
at the local movie theater Robert's a
big film buff he's there all the time he
finally works up the courage to speak to
this girl who has a crush on
and I guess our journey is uh
you know they aspire to be a couple and
it's very messy on the way towards that
and it goes to play extreme places
um
you know yeah
basically touches on the the power
dynamics uh the
miscommunication and the interiority of
dating
um and I play Margot and yeah she works
the concession stand and she's her
head's kind of a little bit up in the
clouds and they text back and forth for
a while and then they finally go on a
date and
that's all I'm gonna say
oh yeah
there's so many what is it like this is
a very very popular story and I'm
curious when you told your friends and
family that you were involved with this
did a lot of them actually know the
material and what was their reaction
when they when you were told them who
you were playing the people who a lot of
some people didn't know it at all but
the people who knew about it were like
oh my God they're making a movie and
we're like oh my God you're gonna play
Robert and so that was you
um
and so you know the people who know this
story I think love it and it matters so
much to them and I think they want our
film to live up to that and they want us
I mean the story is so
compelling but also like cinematic like
when you're reading it you see all the
places you see all the moments you can
see what's happening on their faces and
I don't know I think you feel it like
you know very Instinct you know very
viscerally when you're reading it so
I don't know I think people who knew we
were going to make a movie or
who'd read it we're stoked really
excited yeah did you have any friends
and family that were like oh my God
yeah I mean a friend of mine yeah like
everyone I mean a friend of mine
actually told me to read the short story
I was late to the party and I hadn't
read it when it came out and uh yeah a
friend of mine told me to to read it and
uh because she had a similar experience
and then when I told that friend that we
were gonna make it into movies she was
like oh my gosh so I get credit for that
I was like ah yeah so that yeah
everyone's excited I mean it provokes so
much conversation so you know when
people find out we're making a movie
they're like oh my gosh I hope it
provokes the same amount of reaction and
conversation and and people are
interested you know how our film like
ends and where it goes because you know
short story into a film there's a lot
you've got to kind of add in
um yeah I mean I was there was a lot of
debate in my group of friends when the
story came out in the first place
um and reading it I wasn't immediately
sure how it would translate like I I
knew someone was going to make it into a
movie because when you live in LA and
you make movies every Everybody you read
a story and you're like this is gonna be
a movie in two years I don't know what
the movie will be but this will be
something
um but it was really when I read
Michelle's script which kind of took
took some of those internal experiences
that Margot has and the fears and
projections that she has and made them
into externalized kind of um whether
they're flashes of fear that she has or
projections or just those Thriller and
suspense elements that are that are some
of them psychological for Margot was
sort of Michelle's vision for how to
adapt this very internal story I was
like oh okay this this can borrow some
genre elements while still having the
relatable cringe humor of the story and
hopefully hopefully all of that makes it
feel like bigger than the sum of its
parts as a movie not just a direct
adaptation so that was that was exciting
but yeah I mean everybody was familiar
with it it's such a it it's such a
it's it's that rare relatable short
story that kind of turns into
IP because it has that name recognition
which for a story about dating is not
common you know um so yeah it was
exciting to think about just the reach
it would have even if people are just
like how'd they do that and then they
watch it and then they have their own
thoughts about the movie as a different
piece of art you know one of the things
I thought the film did such a great job
on
um is showing the woman's perspective uh
in a relationship and because as a man I
don't I thought it's hard to describe
this but you know I don't see it from
the woman's side when I'm you know and
it the film does such a great job of
showing your character's perspective on
who is this guy and just being alone on
a street and little things so could you
sort of talk about capturing the women's
you know hopefully you understand what
I'm saying yeah yeah I mean I think we
talked about this a lot just that and
one reason that I think Amelia was so
perfect for this part is that
um Margot is not she's
in the process of you know coming of age
and becoming an adult and trying to
figure out how to be an adult and for
the first time she's living
independently from her family and she's
alone at night and she's going back to a
dorm where people may or may not notice
if she comes back uh at a specific time
so there's a lot of anxiety that just
goes into being a woman of that age or a
woman of any age but in particular when
you're first like thrust out of your
home in that way so but at the same time
we didn't want it to be a story of just
a woman who's a victim of a big scary
world and there's something about Margot
where the fact that she's a good student
the fact that she's funny the fact that
she's self-aware the fact that she has
ego about certain things and she's like
a little cocky about certain things but
also insecure about other things like
there's just a more relatable I think
weigh-in for women you're not looking at
just this like victim final girl type
girl nor is she some like bionically
strong woman who always knows what to
say and like kicks ass all the time
she's kind of just a relatable person
who's
a combination of strong and and also
makes a ton of mistakes
you know even though she can articulate
what she wants probably in every other
area of her life this is the one area
where she can't and that felt really
real and nuanced so yeah I don't know if
that answered your question but it does
but yeah I'm going to get specific with
some stuff that's in the short story and
uh you know I try to I have to ask uh
there's a big thing in the short story
about the bad kiss and I'm just curious
if you guys could talk about filming the
bad kiss and how you want it to feel now
as a director you wanted to put it on
screen
it was really bad really really really
bad yeah
nickel is a really good kiss uh that's
interesting hmm
it was fun to to film I know it was it's
such a weird scene to do and I think
going into that we all knew that and
we'd done a few scenes before that scene
so we kind of already knew each other
and we we got on really well and yeah we
laughed into each other's mouths and it
was from that moment I knew that we'd be
friends for life
honestly that's a very bonding thing
into a mouth that was one of the most
fun nights we were filming especially
because we were filming in
streets of Jersey City I think and
people are driving by yeah yeah yeah
just a really long make out
um uh yeah I mean
I think you know it was important that
it be extremely aggressive
um like like because you know what he
how you kisses how you sleep together
sometimes they say you know and it's
like and she says too like it's probably
gonna be how it would be in bed like
mauling and um and so I think it was
important to like go for it and
I mean what you see in the movie I feels
like 10 like we went to ten yeah you
know I'm it's like
my face is engorged her face and it's
fro you know she's Frozen at your look
at the end when it's done it's just like
yeah
um
so you know and he doesn't want to stop
either it's like he wants to keep going
like you know anyway I could talk about
it because it is really interesting and
and it is an important part of it he
thinks he it's like the first moment
where he thinks he's like killing it you
know later you'll see them at the house
and he thinks he's he's doing a great
job there as well but but with the kiss
he's like I just showed her I can kiss
um so it was an important thing to to
get right I feel like Robert
gets more confident after he sees Marco
cry which is really interesting you know
it kind of you kind of finally see him
be himself and not have this kind of
like guard up but then you're like put
that God back up slightly because that
was so much
yeah I think that I mean yeah that's
very true it feels like well what we
talked about a lot just in terms of like
the psychology of both of those
characters and that date leading up to
that was really
um the idea that they're both kind of
circling each other and Robert is not
sure that he's on safe ground with her
like at any moment he's like oh she
didn't like the movie she she sent this
text and maybe she didn't mean this text
and so he's got his own like swirling
insecurities about the whole thing and
and the way that he handles that is sort
of to push her away just preemptively
before he can get hurt so I think in I
mean it's not a spoiler to say just
because it's the dynamic that kind of
pervades the whole movie but but in that
moment where she's more vulnerable and
she feels
younger and weaker in a way he can then
be the man in a way that he hasn't felt
completely confident in being so I think
he almost becomes like an amplified
version of that and that kiss is like a
good totally yeah expression of that you
know it's that thing where you feel like
someone that the other person has the
higher ground like you're like oh I you
know they have the power but I don't
know if I like the term power Dynamic
it's like it's like you just like them
more than they might like you it's like
you know what I mean it's like yeah
Dynamic but it's like no it is I just
want I think I want them to want me more
than they you know it's just so so when
he has an opportunity to be like oh
I'll show you you know or or you know oh
You're vulnerable well I maybe I'm not
vocalizing it as well as you just did
but but it is exactly I know what you
mean it's like it's also like it's
verbalizing it's the inverse it's the
inverse of what Margot feels in moments
where she's imagining that Robert is
insecure and talking to his therapist
but not to give a spoiler but there's a
moment where she's she's not connecting
with Robert but she kind of spirals out
into a fantasy of Robert confessing his
insecurities about
how inadequate he feels with her to his
therapist and then she's like oh he just
feels inadequate that's why he's being
kind of an right now now I like
him more because poor Robert like she
goes through this whole narrative in her
mind that may or may not be accurate to
what he is feeling but in that moment
she feels a little bit of the power so
she's able to give him another chance so
it's kind of the two of them are just
doing so much projecting yeah and not
enough asking strategizing and
strategizing yeah I uh and I asked you
off before we started if I could ask
about this but I think one of the the
best things in the film is how you
portrayed um would it be specific a sex
scene and showing your character's
perspective and what's going on how the
scene is filmed in real time and like
there's a sense of danger and there's
everything about it I thought was so
well done and I'm just curious if you
the two of you could talk about his
actors filming a scene like that that
really depicts such an honest and
vulnerable moment and everything that's
going on and also how you wanted to
capture it as a director
I mean I I had total and as a trust with
Susanna as a director and as a person
and I loved
um her way of approaching the scene and
um
she did a so obviously we had
storyboards and I remember you sent them
to us before and I could kind of look
through them and and suddenly the scene
became alive in my head and then we all
sat down and we talked in depth about
the scene with Nick
um and uh and the intimacy coordinator
and it kind of just allowed us to talk
everything out you know each picture
each step so it meant that on the day we
could kind of have freedom everyone knew
what was going to happen we knew what
was you know what we were going to do
but at the same time we all trusted each
other and we knew that if anyone was
uncomfortable at any moment we could
voice that and I'm glad that Nick and I
get on really well because
um yeah I can't imagine doing that scene
with anyone else we managed to make a
you know tough scene fun and yeah there
wasn't a moment where I was
uncomfortable or anything
yeah I feel it's the same way as like
you gave us exactly what it was going to
be and you asked us us if it's okay
everything you're seeing there and then
we spoke to the intimacy coordinator
who's kind of like
a mediator to be like are you okay
what's your what are your you know I
think she even took us aside and we're
like you know I was like what are your
limits what are your boundaries what are
you not okay with same with me you know
she she pulled both of us aside
and I think
you know luckily because I think the
scene benefits from it like both of us
were like let's go you know let's do it
all let's make it like as full as it can
be and not hold back
um not to say that you know
if so you know if she wanted to do less
fine the scene was great like the
writing is great what it is but
choreographing it became fun it's like
how do we you know start here and then
what position does he think makes him
like show that he's good at sex and then
you know and like you know how how does
he do it all was fun to figure out okay
and then he I mean I guess I won't go
into each part of it go see the movie if
you want to see how it progresses but
um but I would say it's like the best
case scenario in terms of working on a
scene that's super vulnerable and
I've never done a scene like that I
don't think you've ever done a scene
like that and I've never seen a sex
scene that long except for in the movie
the room
um where there are several uh and
they're all terrible
um but but yeah I think I think it was
yeah I think we we had fun once we got
all the logistical yeah the logistics
permission all that stuff out of the way
and it was clear you know as you said I
mean that scene benefits on also not
like one of the scenes I'm bang my head
on the headboard and it wasn't planned
and I think you know we were both games
same with yeah some of the other stuff
in the third act you know we were both
like let's go you know I we had a
similar way of working which was nice
yeah
because you and uh if you could talk a
little bit about how you wanted to film
that scene yeah I mean I think um
you know I think that I'm a meticulous
planner in general so even when it came
to this scene especially when it came to
the scene it was
you know it was it was a matter of
choreographing the whole thing out like
a ballet basically like okay what is
every move that they're making but at
the same time what are we not seeing and
sometimes just people's imagination and
projecting their own memories and
experiences of their own encounters I
knew would be more Vivid than showing
something very graphic not that we would
have anyway but so it was sort of like
okay if we kind of know enough to know
what's going on beyond the frames of the
camera
um
that will be more evocative for people
so it was sort of just like we knew
every second what was going on whether
or not we were seeing it all and then we
we filmed it in such a way where I think
people just have to be immersed in like
her experience of it and there's not a
moment where they can like take a step
back and watch some sort of a romantic
looking wide shot that's going to fit
into any other romantic story like it
could only be the sex scene in this
movie because you're not actually seeing
anything that's you know erotic you're
just sort of seeing the nuts and bolts
of it from her side
um but yet you're kind of stuck in this
encounter from start to finish in real
time you know
um real fast because I'm out of time I
just want to do a quick individual
question uh you guys were made another
movie together and uh winner and I'm
just curious if you could talk just
brief because I got a rap but just
briefly what can you tell people about
it and obviously as a fan of some show
on HBO I am curious what it's been like
filming the new season and um are you
what are you excited for
you guys go you guys talk winner I mean
Amelia and I just wrapped another movie
together we we're codependent and we're
just gonna keep doing this forever
um uh yeah it's a it is a coming-of-age
story that is also a biopic of reality
winner The Whistleblower so it's a
20-something girl grew up in Texas went
on to become a crypto linguist and then
ended up
um leaking a document and and being
incarcerated for years so Amelia trained
and bulked up and ate protein shakes
every day and it completely transformed
um anyway so yeah that was amazing she's
got an incredible range I mean I haven't
looked at a weight since and I haven't
touched a weight since and I don't think
I will ever touch a white ever again no
I'm joking it was a lot of fun I'm glad
that Susanna trusted me with that film I
I'm brunette and kind of slim so it was
kind of a project that was quite far
away from me and the character was very
different from me but I absolutely loved
it and I loved meeting reality and
talking to her in depth we text all the
time even now and yeah it was an amazing
project to be a part of I was just
trying to get Nick in in a scene I just
wanted him to be in it so somehow
yeah prison guard or yeah NSA worker and
yeah it would have been down just didn't
get the call so I was ready I knew you
guys were filming uh so next time next
time you guys do something just please
include me
um
uh succession is great uh it's called
succession succession yeah that's the
name for the fourth season we'll do yeah
we're gonna keep it the same uh it's
just great it's just a blast you know um
I don't know there's there's we just
have such a great Rhythm together the
writing is excellent it's just the
season is next level it's like it's an
incredible I'm very very impressed every
time we get a script I mean I always
have been but like this season they
continue to be I'm like Jesus Christ
this is like unbelievable so it
continues to be like a total joy to make
and you're back on set tomorrow back on
set tomorrow on that note uh thank you
both all both thank all three of you for
coming in and um uh seriously congrats
on being part of Sundance and uh
seriously have a great day thank you